all right what's going on guys this is
rob and after four days we are here yes
we are here at the conclusion of kingdom
come yes i'm gonna be on a cruise by the
time this video comes out so uh i'll see
y'all in like a week
i'm gonna be getting tanned i'm gonna be
getting drunk i'm gonna be having a
great time hanging out with my sister
right she and i we love taking trips
together so here's what we're gonna do
right here's here's how this whole thing
works this video is basically the end of
it all right the battle the huge
conflict that happens now this is
literally everybody against everybody to
some degree the reality here is that
much like the various vigilantes that
they fought to overcome superman shazam
batman wonder woman all of them there
really aren't any good guys or bad guys
anymore it's really just descended into
superheroes fighting superheroes that's
really all it is because a lot of old
wounds are coming back out now right a
lot of injuries are coming back out a
lot of anger a lot of disdain a lot of
hurt is coming back to the surface and
that's what's happening here we get this
really really cool statement that's
offered where it said is that the only
reason i'm here of course norman mckay
talking to the specter and he says to
watch some hideous judgment superman and
i share the same terror his face is a
mask of confusion he cannot comprehend
how things came to this once upon a time
captain marvel was one of his mightiest
allies now whichever wisdom he once
possessed has been dulled by luthor's
brainwashing making the captain a
soldier of chaos the one warrior who can
counter superman's every move and
prevent him from containing this battle
superman believes himself to be the only
force on earth powerful enough to end
the superhuman war he is wrong and the
reason why is because we transition to
the united nations where a meeting is
being undertaken and you have all these
world leaders who are saying this
multi-megaton nuclear explosion held in
reserve for just this moment that he
says take a look at mankind's last hope
capable of vaporizing a country achieved
in a force field unbreachable by all
catalogued meta-human powers a
deployment system that's virtually
undetectable that essentially they've
been waiting for something like this to
happen and when this thing goes off
there will be casualties there will be
civilians who will die but the reality
and what humanity is arguing here what
this guy's presenting is he's saying
listen to me and understand there is
nothing rational about dispatching
tactical nukes into the heart of our own
country but these are not rational times
we are at the flashpoint of human
existence my god you can hear the battle
even here at any moment it threatens to
spread forth and engulf the world what
then what do we do in that circumstance
and he says the only way to ensure that
future generations remember this as
humanity's final option is to ensure
that there will be future generations
after today let us strike while we still
can god speed and the response is the
united nations fires off these uh these
jets containing tactical nukes and so
jumping back to this major conflict
again it's all heroes fighting heroes
and even norman mckay says that he says
even in the brightest day the dust of
the battle eclipses the sun itself the
prisoners released by marvel's
thunderbolts strike out blindly wonder
woman's troops return force in kind both
sides fight with reckless abandon
whatever heroic moors of combat might
once have ruled them becomes nostalgic
memories this is not a fight that will
eventually die down this is a forest
fire that's just begun a war that may
well end the world any instant now there
will be fatalities and no way to turn
back with superman deadlocked their only
prayer of deliverance rests with a force
from on high and this is the arrival of
batman along with his entire team and he
says batman's legion soars in like a
silent calvary man or machine each agent
knows his mission stem the loss of life
prevent the riot while there's still
time to exert control the sheer force of
batman's presence kindles a desperate
ember of hope too late right like
there's nothing that batman's presence
can do to calm everybody down he does
what he can where he can but in the end
the arrival of batman is not changing
the tide to make things even more
difficult an argument and then
eventually a fight erupts between him
and wonder woman where he tells her this
whole thing that you have this idea of
killing these meta humans you're no
different than those crazy meta humans
themselves right those fanatics the
vigilantes who just believe or who don't
really care about collateral damage
you've become the very thing that you
swore to fight against right this idea
of spreading love and understanding but
don't be afraid to bloody your knuckles
doing it he says at the end of the day
what you're what you're doing here
everything that you're doing here is not
going to win you back your position with
the amazonians you're overcompensating
and in your overcompensation you're
leading to the ending of everything that
wonder woman fires back and it's like
why in the world do you believe you have
any right to condemn me after all these
years of you just vanishing from the
entirety of the landscape we could have
used you after superman left we needed
you and you were nowhere to be found
superman abandoned us and so did you at
a time when we actually needed you the
most you could have been our liaison to
the rest of humanity our eyes and ears
you could have spoken truth to lies you
could have been this person but instead
you weren't but you cowered in your bat
cave turning your entire city into a
some kind of a dictatorship ruling it
with an iron fist who are you to tell me
the problem with operating like some
kind of a dictator after all this time
your hypocrisy still knows no bounce and
in this giant fight between the two of
them suddenly something catches batman's
attention and that's when he sees these
drones these jets flying towards their
conflict with nuclear bombs and that's
when you switch over to the fight
between superman and shazam and it's
just this really amazing fight right
because the entire time shazam is not
holding back and that's one of the big
differences between the two that in the
various conflicts they've had over the
years by whatever manner and whatever
means that billy batson was always the
moral compass right he always held back
because he was never really aiming to
kill that's not the case here right
under the mind control of lex luthor his
job is to kill superman that's his
purpose here so there's no real holding
back here that's why he keeps yelling
shazam that's why he just keeps like
just hitting superman with all this
energy and that's why superman is quite
literally dying in this fight and in a
lot of ways people see it happen but
they're so caught up with their own
battles that they actually end up
missing the fact that superman is being
killed by shazam and so switching back
to wonder woman in batman batman says
open your eyes diana right your answer
flies on metal wings those are nuclear
carriers the ultimate war bringers our
war is not one uh one act of violence at
the cost of some lies our war ends in
extinction if you're that devoted to the
amazon honor if your soul genuinely
longs for atonement on amazonian terms
then let's keep fighting and let the
planes do their work and the response of
wonder woman is no and she ultimately
stands down and the two of them end up
going after these drones the problem
here is that as norman mckay is watching
this he says despite my spectral form i
feel the heat of batman's lasers i feel
the strain of titanium muscles and i
hear the whisper of a pilot begging for
forgiveness because they missed one and
one of the bombs comes falling down to
its destination they couldn't get to it
in time and so what happens is you end
up having superman who just seizes
shazam right just grabs his mouth and
billy batson turns back into his human
form and norman mckay says for one
frozen instant the storm clears fingers
that can fuse coal into diamond crawl
across human bone and in the hush of
ears that can hear a cell divide pick
out with chilling ease the scream of
human rage a wave of x-rays confirms the
bomb's potency a telescopic glance
calculates the seconds before impact he
has to act now and that's when spectre
says it is time right judgment has come
norman mckay the hour tolls our entire
journey has brought us to this moment
and he says judge and judge wisely that
the specter needs a human host and he
puts the responsibility on norman mckay
and says you have witnessed all of this
you've seen all of this unfold norman
mckay judge who will be condemned in
this will it be humanity that will end
or will it be will it be the meta humans
that will end what will happen here and
so it's this really really just
beautiful and amazing moment because
we're told superman's palm spasms around
batson's jaw and batson whimpers the
clock is racing only moments remain
before the blast and superman says
listen to me billy listen harder than
you have ever listened before and he
says look around us look at what we've
come to there's a bomb falling either it
kills us or we run rampant across the
globe i can still stop the bomb billy
that much i'm sure of what i don't know
is whether i should be allowed to
superhumans or mankind one will pay the
ultimate price and that decision billy
batson is not for me to make i am not a
god i am not a man but you billy you're
both and so he says more than anyone who
has ever existed you know what it's like
to live in both worlds only you can
weigh their worth equally fight the
brainwashing billy you can let me go or
with a word you can stop me do you
understand the choice that can be made
by you alone and norma mckay chimes in
and says the tears of billy batson
answer this question for superman and
superman says then decide decide the
world and ultimately superman takes off
and in the moment when superman leaves
billy batson yells shazam and the seven
thunders come crashing down billy turns
back into shazam again grabs superman
smashes him into the ground and goes
flying up to the bomb now it's one of
these crazy moments because when this
happens everybody stops fighting like
everybody stops and they're just
watching shazam as he's racing up to
this nuclear bomb that's going to
annihilate them all he shouts shazam
three times the bomb goes off and billy
batson dies like literally he sacrifices
himself to save every superhero here and
all the specter says is judgment right
this just super iconic scene of superman
on his knees screaming if you ever saw
that shot that's where that's from it's
from kingdom come and he's just
surrounded by dead bodies that's it when
he gets up superman is eight kinds of
pissed this guy is incensed and
ultimately the specter's like i've done
my job right judgment has been has been
passed it's time for me to go he
literally bids norman mckay for a while
and norma's like no you're not going
anywhere right like you're bound to me
right like you're literally your spirit
is bound to me if only in the moment if
you really believe that letting superman
just race off and whatever happens next
is just you know it's whatever that's
what's truly evil because all i saw here
was bedlam and tragedy sadness right
just a man who made a series of bad
decisions and led everything to this if
you leave now then that really is an
evil thing and so ultimately we end up
following them to the united nations
where superman's going and this guy
starts to unleash holy hell i mean just
like starts to rip down the ceiling
right he's going to kill everybody here
he's going to kill every single person
here and the specter says after 10 years
superman has finally let free a wrath
that would cower satan himself how can
any man possibly calm the fury that he
feels towards his prosecutors and that's
when norman mckay steps up and he says
clark don't do this right you blame
yourself for captain marvel for magog
and kansas for 10 years that ended today
yes you're angry but in that anger
you're forgetting once more what humans
feel this is what humanity has been
feeling for a long time humanity didn't
just fire off these rockets at you to
annihilate you because you just pissed
them off one last time it's because all
they've known since your emergence the
emergence of metahumans is fear they
might follow you they might smile at you
but at the end of the day in their heart
of hearts they're scared of you because
you tower above them you fly above them
you spend your time above them they
never really see you exist in a
watchtower that literally orbits the
world right like you are always in a
state above them all they know is fear
you are an omnipresent reminder that
they are not you and how easy it would
be for you to destroy them and that's
when superman asks who are you and why
are you here and norman says listen to
me clark he says of all the things that
you can do all of your powers the
greatest has always been your
instinctive knowledge of right and wrong
it was a gift of your own humanity you
never had to question your choices in
any situation any crisis you always knew
what to do but the minute that you made
the super more important than the man
the day you decided to turn your back on
mankind that completely cost you your
instinct that took your judgment away
and he says take it back if you want
redemption clark it lies in the very
next decision that you make make it as a
man and make it right and so ultimately
when he's met by the arrival of all
these survivors he's shocked by it all
he's like how did anybody survive and
we're basically told that between the
flash and between green lantern and what
have you that basically some heroes were
protected or some meta-humans were
protected the big concern though is that
humanity still has the same level of
distrust like magog is among these
people who has survived right there's
still the same level of distrust the
same everything right and the question
of wonder woman is what do we do now
right like what do we do now clark it's
still the same thing like we're still
super like there's less of us but we're
still meta humans right there's still
those individuals out there who believe
that that fighting is the only way to
solve problems and to a degree that's
true right violence is not always the
answer but it is a answer and it's
usually a very effective one and the
response to superman is years ago i let
those that i swore to protect drive me
away we all did and that was the day all
of this began and and these people say
like we saw you as gods and superman
says so did we we saw ourselves as gods
too who could somehow lead you into a
better place but that's not what you
need that's not what humanity needed
humanity did not need to be a horse that
we strapped a rope to and led to water
what humanity needed was someone to show
them how to get there what you needed
was for us to live among you to be a
part of you but not to be above you and
that will change from this point going
forward we will no longer operate above
all of you we will work alongside you we
will work with you we will help you make
the world a better place we will offer
our wisdom and our guidance from our own
experiences we will bring that to the
table i can bring you wisdom and
guidance from a long dead civilization
that's that was vastly more more
advanced than yours was at the time that
it expired batman is the most
intelligent person in the world wonder
woman has the experience and wisdom of
quite literally gods
we can bring all of this to the table
and we can help make you better and
we're going to do this by also using the
wisdom of a man who left his legacy on
the world by sacrificing his life of
billy batson and they actually end up
using the cape of billy batson as one of
the flags at the united nations and so
what you get is this sort of epilogue
where you end up finding out that wayne
manor has basically been rebuilt it's
been turned into a hospital to treat
those who survived the entirety of the
soup of the metahuman conflict but it'll
also serve as basically a way to kind of
keep those detained uh lex luthor's one
of those
[Laughter]
superman of course is recovering he's
accompanied by wonder woman who's also
probably offering her own methods of
recovery for superman if you know what i
mean but you also have wonder woman
regaining her ranks among the amazonians
right having basically ushered the world
into a better place what you get in the
aftermath of this meta-human conflict is
really a utopia you get an entire utopia
here and it's a wonderful and a
beautiful thing because a lot of these
graves are built in remembrance of those
individuals who died and clark kent
actually starts working to set kansas
back to a place where it can be it can
go back to being the bread basket right
you can go back to growing crops and
different things along those lines they
lead the world into a much better place
and to a utopia that they always wanted
it to be and that right there is the
value of violence had this entire
meta-human conflict never taken place in
the in the first place would this future
ever have come to fruition would it have
ever happened and the answer is most
likely no if superman had stayed hands
off if he had remained in his fortress
and never gotten involved you likely
would have seen some kind of a nuclear
response by humanity and the world would
have just been plunged into chaos those
meta-humans who did survive would have
annihilated what remained of humanity
and they would have taken the world for
themselves and that would have been the
end of it right that what it took was a
massive conflict it took death and
destruction on that scale in order to
force the change of both humanity and
meta-humans because it's only in the
face of such tragic loss that we're
actually forced to confront what caused
that loss in the first place in that
moment we're caught up we're all
emotionally swept up with everything
that's going on right that's exactly
what happened here superman wonder woman
batman green lantern the flash humanity
likes luther so on and so forth they
were so caught up in the situation that
no one ever stopped to take a step back
and ask the question how did we get here
what led us to this point it was only
when humanity were when the many humans
were facing their own extinction at the
hands of a nuclear arsenal and that near
extinction came to fruition had it not
been for billy batson had if that bomb
had detonated to ground zero they all
would have been killed likely superman
too i don't know if that would have been
the case but presumably it would have
been maybe you would have survived i
don't know but the thing is most the
entire meta-human population would have
been destroyed right like it was only in
the face of their own extinction and
annihilation that they were finally able
to to heal black appeal back this this
cloak right this blanket of destruction
and death and despair and come to terms
with what they've done and the fact that
superman himself had led the hero the
metahuman community on this collision
course it was his actions that led
things to getting where they were and so
everything is really kind of settling
back down norman mckay finds his own
measure of hope reaffirms his conviction
in god goes back to reading the bible
and this congregation grows it's that
kind of thing this serves a greater
purpose what's really cool is like the
specter as jim corgan shows up to listen
to his sermon at one point in time
that's the beauty of it all and so of
course for the first time in the story
you have a superman and you've got a
wonder woman who basically show up to
planet krypton where they sit down and
they basically realize everybody's
dressed up as superheroes not gonna lie
i would go to this place if this place
existed in the real world i don't know
if it does and if it does exist i will
go to wherever i need to be in order to
be able to go there but i would
absolutely go to this place 100 and in
fact you know what like if this is
something that's like a major kind of a
convention right like they do this at
san diego comic con we should all go
right i mean i don't know if you know
one or two point what the 2.132 million
three 130 thousand people can fit in
there but uh we'll try so like i would
love
[Laughter]
i would love like to go to a place like
this it just looks amazing but at the
end of the day it's really the three of
them just kind of sitting down and
having this conversation and really just
being a part of humanity not really
above them not really beyond them not
operating outside of them but basically
being among them and just kind of
enjoying their life among people having
this conversation talking about
everything that's going on right that
you know batman and having this
conversation says that it's been a long
road for rehabilitation for the for all
the injured he says fortunately i'm not
laboring alone i was able to put several
members of the mankind liberation front
to work in our ad hoc hospital and when
he says he put him to work he means like
slap collars around their necks and made
him work which rightfully they deserved
he says they're pulling their weight
vandal savage alone has picked up quite
a few healing tricks in his 50 000 years
that's really them just kind of talking
about everything that's happening having
this conversation and what's really
really cool is you end up finding out
that uh wonder woman and superman they
kind of got something going on right
that batman's a little pissed off
because the stick is well done which i
you know you know i can't even judge him
for that whatever man but you have this
moment where like wonder woman and
batman or superman are like hey we kind
of have something to share and batman's
like yeah you're pregnant i already know
like i know you're pregnant wonder woman
right so like superman knocked up wonder
woman making a life for himself that's
really what's going on here it's just
kind of going forward right they want
batman to be the godfather which i don't
know why anybody would ask that right i
would never ask batman to be the
godfather of my child ever well there
would be okay i'll take that back there
would be rules i would be like he has to
be a robin at least once he has to be
set up financially for the rest of his
life or her life or whatever they have
to be able to drive the batmobile at
least one time like they have to be able
to take the batmobile to prom that's
that's like a rule right like i mean i
don't know how i would reinforce that
i'd be dead if batman was like if it
came to that right i would have been
dead hence the nature of a godfather but
i'd be like you have to let my child
take the batmobile to prom because how
dope would that be you'd be walking away
with other people's prom dates you know
but nonetheless it's just one of those
things right you got to take you got to
have the batmobile taking the batmobile
to problem will be legit but again kind
of being more serious here right getting
back down to a serious tone and talking
about all this it really is everything
coming to a close right this world has
achieved a level of peace and a level of
of understanding and really a utopia
that was previously never thought
possible all it took was the near
extinction of the entirety of the
meta-human race coming from a decision
that humanity didn't want to make in
order for it to happen but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
to an end this was the story of kingdom
come absolutely loved it let me know
what you guys think about it and i will
catch you all later
peace